welcome to
to the floating islands of Lake Titicaca
from puno peru
but there what happens is there's a lot
rain
they are a bit adrift and there
problems then the cigars decide
move here to one a place where
could be with more security more
before we lived a little more
it can be being more errant they are more
undisturbed
on the point the tourists the agencies
they start to take tourists home
then we feel the need
we have you tourists who visit us
as we are doing now we are not going
to explain our identity they
they would go outside to look for work employment
but now as there was more tourism
then it was convenient for them to return
so she always thought that
I only had the opportunity in the
city
then when they knocked on the doors
then more
because seeing the new equipment changed with
tourism can do many things
you can work now too now
study at the university
then they are studying many have
started studying tourism has studied
things but in these 50 years has not
changed suddenly in our life but
they are linked because they are not
the fact that they have a profession
they have disconnected from them continue
fishing they are still hunting
collecting eggs his life as pure
this is still the same then it is very
important why that says possibly
from achilles
can go to work
talk value more culture
what is the truth not because sometimes not
comes from outside does not know the reality
but no
symbol of freedom and in those of saving
is we resist to disappear
now
they are all wrong
we still all want
before his destiny he was in the hands of
travel agencies and other people
now they are starting to become more
owners of your destination
they start to have
feel more proud of being pure
our